way along the mall and as he was saying
adam through horse guards
through the arch and down to the
sovereign's entrance
and alastair i remember you know in an
exclusive you talked to her majesty
about the crown jewels
i mean obviously they're symbolic but
but what do they really mean to her
well i remember her being very amusing
about actually wearing a crown and how
you have to lift the speech up to your
face rather than
tilt your head forward to reach to read
the speech and she said
otherwise she'd either break her neck or
it would fall off
and i think that because it's two and a
half
pounds in weight it's made with two
or more thousand diamonds it's got other
great stains which when we get a chance
to look at it i'll take us through
because
literally it is it is an object that
contains
objects from the whole of our history
going back to saxon times
but it is not an easy thing to wear
just going uh in fact the queen won't be
wearing the queen won't be wearing it
today it'll be carried for her by the
lord great chamberlin
and i suspect that as even when she was
in her robes the last time she had it
carried also
she has probably taken the view that
this is not a
headdress that she will comfortably wear
again
in her mid-90s just going under the arch
there at
horse guards parade and she's going to
be accompanied we understand by
her son the air to the throne
yes the prince of wales and the duchess
of cornwall will come from
clarence house a little later on they
will meet the queen
at the palace of westminster but they
will arrive slightly ahead of her
and then she will be escorted with them
present down to the chamber itself
it's good to see some horses in horse
guards parade
very popular with tourists but the
normal
horse boxes on whitehall have been shot
during the pandemic but i see they've
been opened up
again today it's
turning out the guard and in fact queen
victoria passed through there once and
the queen's lifeguard had forgotten
and so she insisted that for a hundred
years they would turn out every day at
four o'clock
in fact they still do it because the
tradition was seen to be rather
a joyous one and the tourists have
enjoyed it obviously before
covid but now on to whitehall
and all the principal offices of the
secretaries of state to the queen and
the crown i suppose because it does
represent
the power in the land for instance every
time you get your income tax return
it's got a crown represented on it it
appears on our currency
it appears on police officers
helmets and also on our post boxes so
it's ubiquitous in britain and it
contains a great deal of our history
but it is a symbol of the power that
actually
is vested in the people of the united
kingdom who choose the parliament that
is sovereign
and just a reminder this is the the
crown arriving
at uh parliament for the state opening
uh
manchester queen not in this particular
motorcade she'll be coming
uh in one later and does it work alice
said that they wait for the crown to
arrive before
uh the monarch leaves buckian palace
well not quite they'll make sure that
the queen arrives at the precise time
that has been scheduled and that
probably has been timed because they do
this at buckingham palace they check
the timings of everything you can see at
the base of the victoria tower the
massive arch
that was deliberately designed to be
this formal entrance
of the third part of the constitution
the crown
which is itself by authority the first
but the two that are always here the
lords and commons and when the monarch
arrives she comes
in as she will after the crown later on
and literally just inside
that arch there is an entrance to the
great sovereign staircase
and the crown will be taken up there to
the raving room ready for when the queen
arrives later on and we understand now
that the queen
doesn't use the stairs she uses a lift
is that right
well i think it's much easier and she's
done that for a few years now
very quietly and there is a lift that
brings you out literally on the
principal corridor right beside the
entrance to the
to the raving room so very easily she
can get in and be prepared but as i say
she's wearing a day dress today we don't
yet know precisely what she's going to
wear but
it'll be just a comfortable outfit she
tends to make a decision on the day
depending on the weather and i don't
know what it's like in london
necessarily but it's been a bit
changeable yeah a little bit cloudy it
looked uh
looked like uh a sort of um
superhero movie behind ian king earlier
on with the
the sky but it's clear it's not raining
yet
uh alastair now thank you very much
indeed we await
her manchester's journey to buckingham
palace with me
is our political editor uh beth rigby
i mean beth one of the games always
played with queen speeches
is just how busy mps are going to be how
many bills there are
and you know what's likely to run into
trouble
with mps any ideas well there's 25 bills
i think
but don't hold me to that but about a
couple of dozen
let's put it that way and then in terms
of
what might agitate mps well as i was
saying earlier i think
in terms of constitutional issues or
electoral issues
certainly the voter id uh bill is a huge
issue uh there have been suggestions
that 3.5
million of of lower income voters and
people across the country just simply
don't have
photo id they don't have a we already
have david davis making a noise yeah
yeah so so that will be that will be uh
very uh controversial in fact labour's
shadow justice secretary
uh david lammy has criticized these
plans
uh and he said you know in the 2019
election there was just one conviction
for
voter thought 3.5 million british
citizens do not have
photo id so i think that would be very
controversial
it might not be hugely controversial on
the tory benches
but it will be definitely a big talking
point and then of course social care
i mean this was the promise 22 months
ago
to bring forward a comprehensive
plan for social care what do we know
where we expect that there will be
proposals
brought forward will there actually be a
bill there will be a health
and care bill but that might be more
about integrating
health and social care rather than
actually reform in the social care
system
and already before the queen has even
made
her speech before mps are even in the
chambers damien greene
uh the former deputy prime minister
saying this morning i'm frustrated it's
taken so long to get to this stage
this needs to be the year for action and
decision rather than kicking the can
down the road but as i understand it i'm
not expecting an
actual bill on social care and that
really is
a huge challenge uh for boris johnson's
government how to reform social care
theresa may had a go at it didn't she in
2017 and it became
well well i was going to say it became
the achilles hill heel of her general
election then it was kicked into the
long grass
this has been discussed for a decade now
how to fix it
and i think mps will be disappointed uh
if a bill is not brought forward
proposals and a bill are different
things
and the other question of course is
going to be which ministers will be
bringing forward
which bills we've had this uh mini shake
up in the
shadow team what about the real cabinet
can we expect that
there will be changes in in the cabinet
sooner reshuffle
well earlier this year uh government
figures suggested to me that the prime
minister would do a reshuffle towards
the end
of the parliamentary term so that would
be into the summer so
june into july and there has been talk
about it but
in terms of where they are right now
they've just had this thumping
uh victory in the elections i do think
that there is a sense
uh within government that there are some
posts
where they perhaps need more muscular
cabinet ministers there has been some
criticism that some of the
biggest and best talent is actually
outside the cabinet not
inside the cabinet we know also though
that boris johnson
likes to be the undisputed leader rather
than perhaps the first among you i mean
someone was saying to me last night it's
quite interesting
that you know we haven't heard much from
jacob rees-mogg for example
uh seems to have been very firmly put
back in his box after being quite
prominent
well jacob rees-mogg was very supportive
of the prime minister in his bid to
become
leader he was one of uh the
mps one of the senior mps in the erg the
the brexit skeptic the euro skeptic
group sorry
that um backed boris johnson he was
awarded with that uh
leader of the commons position but there
have been a couple of
issues where he creates headlines uh
where they don't really like it
um but he seems secure in that post
let's uh go over to aleister bruce for
more ceremonial alistar i think this is
the uh motorcade of the prince of wales
who uh
of course given her majesty's age is uh
becoming more and more
prominent in public life
well the prince of wales has become the
patriarch of the family following the
death of his father the duke of
edinburgh
and he has for some time been supporting
the queen at
significant events and he has already
supported her at previous state openings
of parliament
so this is entirely in line he's coming
with the duchess of cornwall
and they will be sat to the queen's left
as she reads the speech from the throne
and in a place really that was
established when they created the house
of lords and that great golden
canopy over the throne a place for
queen victoria's son albert edward then
prince of wales
who became edward vii but for the prince
of wales coming
to parliament you're right it is clear
that
there will be a greater degree of
expectation upon him to support the
queen
in her role as head of state
truly fantastic aerial shots i have to
say showing
horse guards very much to an advantage
it's a it's a privilege isn't it a privy
councillors alice so that they can
take a take their cars through the arch
is that right
yes certain people had what was called
the ivory pass
and if you held an ivory pass
particularly in the old days
it used to be secretaries of state and
therefore rightly
privy councillors they could show it at
the form of
security that existed back in the
edwardian period and the ivory past let
you through
but it used to be horse guards the
principal
entrance to whitehall palace and that's
why it is still
given the principal regiment of the army
the
household cavalry regiment to act as the
guards there which seems such a long way
away
from where the queen actually lives at
buckingham palace but we always remember
these traditions the principles passing
the cenotaph
there therefore very close now on
parliament street to coming
to the palace of westminster itself and
they're all very good roads are they not
for ceremonial routes
especially when there's nobody on them
yeah well they've been specially
designed haven't they with removable
street furniture
so there's no uh traffic lights or
bollards or
uh all the usual stuff we get in the
streets to hold people up although of
course uh these days with worries about
uh
the crowds uh there are a lot of
temporary barriers put up as we've seen
uh there in fact again i think more
temporary barriers this year
than we've ever seen before and of
course you know we are seeing from these
pictures
the state of disrepair that the palace
of westminster is in
with scaffolding and tarpaulins in many
areas including of course on
the symbolic big ben and
beth i think it's fair to say they still
haven't quite resolved how they're going
to
renovate the house of commons and what
was good i was just looking at those
pictures thinking isn't it a shame and
when you go inside as well and you'll
know this
it really is quite dilapidated inside as
well i mean it really
there are almost buckets in the corridor
yeah it needs more than a makeover
doesn't it need to re a complete kind of
re of gutting really um but yes there
are still debates on going about
um when does parliament
uh when is it evacuated if you like
there's big ben
and i know and you know uh restored art
should
should the commons move to the lord
should the lords move out to buildings
um
in the vicinity uh and it hasn't been
resolved
actually it's still under debate yeah
but uh i think they have mp's decided
they're not going to move
their commons chamber out of london
although there's no there was
yeah there was some discussions about
whether they move it to another part of
the country but i think that
that won't happen uh the most the
obvious thing to do would be to move it
to another part of the government
estate around westminster but again lots
of mps are very reluctant to leave the
chambers
because once they move out i mean it
i can't remember how long it is but it
is many years it's not just a quick
you know home improvement show
and you're back in i mean it will take
years it will take years for
for it to happen so it would be a big
you know be a big moment to move mps out
for for an indefinite period of time of
course some questions about the future
of buckingham palace itself not that the
building
won't stay there of course it will but i
think uh the
monarch actually offered it as a
temporary base for parliament uh
if they needed one in westminster that
wasn't an idea that didn't
fly but some suggestions that perhaps uh
uh when there is a change of monarch
that uh
it may he knew monarch might decide not
to
reside in buckingham palace and it may
become more of a sort of public building
interesting see that happens we're
waiting for her majesty the queen to
leave to come to the
palace of westminster for
her speech opening parliament the
gracious speech as they refer to it
she's due to be delivering that speech
in little over 15 minutes i think
things will move forward fairly quickly
from
this point also interesting isn't it
sometimes both how
the government who write the queen's
speech they literally put the words in
here
and sometimes they get a bit cheeky and
put their own slogans in i remember new
labour put
tough on crime and tough on the causes
of crime in her majesty's mouth
exactly it would be very interesting to
see if any boris johnson slogans find
their way into uh the her majesty's
speech and
uh whether they will you know use
buildback better or levelling
up uh with those words coming from the
queen's mouth we'll find out soon enough
the other thing we often get
announcements of in the queen's speech
is any visits
she's going to make yeah or any state
visits but i suppose
in this time of covid that's less likely
no and
yes so she would she would make
announcement but but yeah it's less
likely
we saw didn't we in terms of just
foreign visits the prime minister
himself having to cancel
uh that trip uh to india in january he
was meant to go it was postponed because
of our lockdown
and then he was meant to go again uh in
april and that was postponed because of
india's terrible cavity and then the g7
foreign ministers
which wasn't in person media didn't go
to no there were two
two cases of uh kovid found there
uh in june though the world is coming to
the uk and to cornwall
uh where we are going to host uh the g7
summit and i think the us president will
will be here so there will be a big
international event and it will be on
our shores
uh we won't have to go anywhere lots of
fresh air in cornwall
not complaining blow the virus away i'm
sure
our lord's waiting i think i'm writing
saying that they had a ballot
as to who could sit in the chamber yeah
because
typically you would have you'd expect
600 people to be around for this
event i think there's about a hundred so
yeah there's only a limited
uh number of lords allowed in the
chamber so it'd be a much more
uh subdued affair uh than it normally
is but maybe uh the next one around will
be back to normal
and a new lord speaker john mcfall from
labour taking over from
norman fowler so he'll be
involved in the ceremony at some point
but i think the key person is the lord
chancellor
and there's the senior representative of
the
of the government
mps too i imagine are limited in again
yeah limited limited numbers in the
chamber as well although
it will be the first time we see uh
boris johnson and kierstarma
uh face to face after that election
drab in first armor and and victory for
for the prime minister
well let's go over to uh alastair bruce
now
for i think her majesty's motorcade
going to make his way
to western west allister
the queen coming out of the garden gate
saluted by the
guard of buckingham palace and taken in
a range rover
today with her lady in waiting
who is the lady elizabeth leeming
and they're followed by a private
secretary
who is sir edward young
and also the queen's aquarium waiting
major tom white quite interesting that
the
mall which always looks such a perfect
processional route
for buckingham palace was in fact there
before the palace was built
it was a place that people went to
promenade and to play
a game called pelhamelli and so the mal
word comes from that and yet it was
turned in
edward the seventh reign into this
fabulous slightly red
tinted professional route and
it's been perfectly suited to taking
monarchs to parliament
this is the 67th occasion during the
queen's reign
that she has opened a parliament
and as you were discussing earlier on
the queen opens parliaments at the
beginning
of the parliament itself which is
generally five years
or at the start of each session
during that five years
so the queen will be supported when she
arrives at
the palace of westminster by her son and
daughter-in-law
but of course before she left she was
assured that there was a hostage
waiting in the palace for her safe
return on this occasion mr marcus jones
mp
who is the vice chamberlain of the
household he arrived at the palace
earlier today was met by the lord
chamberlain
and he gets to sit down and i hope watch
sky news
and see what happens because as long as
the queen returns safely he is then
released
and allowed to get back to parliament
for the debates this afternoon it was on
this very spot where the queen is
passing
that um she was shot at
by someone with a fake pistol
back in the early 1980s an occasion that
reminded us that public life can
sometimes carry its dangers
alistair i was going to say that the
queen traveling in
a range rover i mean that is very much
dressed down isn't it
we had much smarter limousines rolls
royce for the
uh crown and i think uh for prince
charles it was a daimler or something
this is this is a sort of down to earth
statement although of course range
rovers
are quite posh cars
[Applause]
i think the queen has always had a very
practical view on things
and receiving the salute there from the
queen's lifeguard
of for her this is an occasion where
there isn't the pageantry
there isn't the troops lining the roots
apart from the lifeguard there and of
course the buckingham palace god which
had been turned out
and therefore there is no point in
doing things up in some way that's not
necessary
and the queen doesn't tend to want any
more fuss
about herself than is necessary for the
job
that's being done so for her this is a
practical
transfer from the palace to
the palace of westminster and of course
it will give her the chance to
um to be very quickly swept back
afterwards for a good lunch
and the queen i think it's her 67th
speech she's actually delivered herself
is that right
that's correct and there have been
occasions when she's missed it
she was unable to attend when she was
expecting
the birth of prince andrew and prince
edward in 1959
and 1963 and there was no state opening
at all in 2011
2018 and 2020 and the speaker's
procession
now making its way into the house of
commons for prayers and a reminder that
all of this is
carefully brought together in that way
that britain does rather well
and choreographed to the last second
and after prayers the commons will be
ready to receive the sovereign command
from black rod in order to attend upon
her majesty immediately and the house
[Music]
appears
speaker taking his chair the mace being
put in place
it's because the queen is returning to
parliament
that the mace which is a symbol of her
authority is released again to be used
and to make the sittings formal in both
the
lords and the commons although the lords
receive their mace after the queen has
left
there is the canopy above the queen's
throne
and beside it on the right the table on
which the
imperial state crown the symbol of the
monarchy will be placed and you can see
the
chairs to the right where the prince of
wales and the duchess of cornwall
will sit and either side of the queen
will be carried the
cap of maintenance and the sword of
state
lord chief justice on what are called
the wool sacks a reminder
from the middle ages that the wealth
of england was derived from the wool
from the sheep the bishop of london on
the bishop's bench
they're the only people in the house of
lords to have a little arm at the end of
their bench in order to
keep them propped up and comfortable
interestingly all the robes that they're
wearing have provenance going way back
to the middle ages again
the robe worn by most peers is divided
down the center
on the right hand side you have a number
of bars
of gold and urban according to the rank
in the periods that they hold
two meaning baron and on the left hand
side there is an open arm
which reminds us of the spiritual side
of the makeup of the house lord so
spiritual and temporal temporal being
the land spiritual
being of god and everything else so
these robes have again been seen in all
the illustrations
of the house of lords and can be seen
being worn back in the tudor period
so i can tell you that those are two
barons of baroness and the baron and it
you can just tell because if you're a
duke you have
four rows of gold and herman
two for a baron two and a half
four by counts three for an earl three
and a half for a marquis
so everything carefully regulated and
i'm sure
nobody much cares to know all that
detail but it does show that there's
nothing done
in any of the ritual and ceremony that
we see in the united kingdom that
doesn't have a provenance or reason
and in a way discovering all of that can
be quite interesting
and the most senior member of the
peerage they actually get a role in in
this ceremony is that
well the dukes if they're here do indeed
i'm
of course the most senior person after
the monarch is
the archbishop of canterbury who is not
present today would seem
but bishops are still under certain
restrictions
and with precedence given to new
women bishops over men given permission
and a right to sit in the house of lords
under the current makeup
but the principal rank of the peerage is
duke
and they're like princes really and
we're always
in the old days if a duke stood uh
everyone would shout in the house of
lords duke and whoever was speaking had
to shut up and listen
to what the duke had to say but those
days are long behind us
one bit of ceremonial i noticed alistair
they did go
through with was the beefeaters
searching
parliament
well no one forgets 1605 and although
the fixed term parliament act puts the
opening of parliament
in may it generally was in
november time and that is why we have
the gunpowder plot
marked in november as as it took place
in 1605 and
had the plan been successful
it would have exploded the king and all
his government and
all parliament and it would have
achieved the aims of those who were
seeking to put
that challenge in the way of fate but
still you're right adam they check every
state opening day
i can hear the trumpets that is the
sovereign salute which means the queen
is leaving
the royal raving room and making her way
through the royal gallery the prince's
chamber
and she will shortly be coming into the
chamber and as her procession does
the lord's ships will stand and
emergency the queen will go
to the throne uh when she is
in position her procession has settled
and the prince of wales and the duchess
of cornwall are in place
she'll say my lord's pray be seated and
they will then sit down
she will then wait a few moments and she
will then
give a signal to the lord great
chamberlain who is democracy chumley who
will then in
turn raise a white wand
to send the message to black rod who's
waiting
uh in the central lobby to summon
on the queen's instructions the commons
to the bar of the lords
and we will have the privilege of seeing
that most important part of our
constitution
that the door of the commons is slammed
in the face of the queen's messenger
to remind her majesty is looking at this
moment from that throne
straight down the corridor that she has
no place
in the house of commons here comes the
queen's procession
into the house of lords
underestimated
um
my lord's prayer visited
the imperial state crime will be placed
beside her majesty the queen
[Laughter]
and in order to meet with covert
instructions
the queen's instructions have now been
given
to the lord great chamberlain and he has
waved
his white wand and the message is now
passed
to summon the commons to the lords and
there's always a sort of
weight while this takes place in the
house of lords
black rod an appointment
coming from the time of edward the third
the door slammed in the queen's
authority
it's black rod open the door
she will proceed and will bow to the
speaker and both sides of the house and
then deliver the message
mr speaker the queen commands it
out of peers
and adam very much as you said we'll now
see a reduced number
making their way to the bar in the house
of commons but the
mace the symbol of the queen's authority
in the commons that with it present
the exercising of the powers of
the chamber can be exercised and now
very carefully
those who need to make their way to the
lords
going in observance of
the rules we all live by today
so
well social distancing between
politicians uh preventing the need of
any of those awkward
conversations between opponents we
sometimes see boris johnson
striding ahead of uh
and everyone else following in single
file
adam on those occasions when my other
roles have had me waiting
in the house of lords for the arrival of
the commons it's very interesting you
hear this
sort of river of noise as the members of
the house of commons exercising their
right to have a jolly good chat on the
way up
come in and they continue this
conversation that raw goes on
at this point about her majesty the
queen from
speaker and black rod and
chaplin's come in chief clark
and you'll notice as discussed earlier
the care with which everyone is placed
and then the
earl marshall the duke of norfolk
doesn't have to give
the signal this time to the
lord chancellor in the same way because
the speech is already
for her majesty at her fingertips
the queen's speech
my lords and members of the house of
commons
my government's priority is to deliver a
national recovery from the pandemic
that makes the united kingdom stronger
healthier
and more prosperous than before
to achieve this my government will level
up opportunities
across all parts of the united kingdom
supporting jobs
businesses and economic growth and
addressing the impact of the pandemic
on public services
my government will protect the health of
the nation
continuing the vaccination program and
providing
additional funding to support the nhs
my ministers will bring forward
legislation
to empower the nhs to innovate and
embrace technology
patients will receive more tailored and
preventative care closer to home
measures will be brought forward to
support the health and well-being of the
nation
including to tackle obesity and improve
mental health
proposals on social care reform will be
brought forward
my government will build on the success
of the vaccination program
to lead the world in life sciences
pioneering new treatments against
diseases like
cancer and securing jobs and investment
across the country
my ministers will oversee the fastest
ever increase in public funding
for research and development and passed
legislation
to establish an advanced research agency
following the unprecedented support
provided to businesses during the
pandemic
proposals will be brought forward to
create
and support jobs and improve regulation
my government will strengthen the
economic ties across the union
investing in and improving national
infrastructure
proposals will be taken forward to
transform
connectivity by rail and bus and to
extend
5g mobile coverage and gigabit
capable broadband
legislation will support a lifetime
skills guarantee
to enable flexible access to high
quality education and training
throughout people's lives
measures will be introduced to ensure
that support for businesses
reflects the united kingdom's strategic
interests
and drives economic growth
laws will simplify procurement in the
public session
sector eight new freeports will create
hubs for trade and help regenerate
communities my government will ensure
that the public finances
are returned to a sustainable path once
the economic recovery
is secure
measures will be brought forward to
ensure that children have the best start
in life
prioritizing their early years
my ministers will address lost learning
during the pandemic
and ensure every child has a high
quality education
and is able to fulfill their potential
my government will help more people to
own their own home
while enhancing the rights of those who
rent
laws to modernize the planning system so
that more homes can be built
will be brought forward along with
measures to end the practice of ground
rents for new leasehold properties
my ministers will establish in law a new
building safety regulator
to ensure that the tragedies of the past
are never repeated
measures will be brought forward to
address racial and ethnic disparities
and ban conversion therapy
legislation will support the voluntary
sector
by reducing unnecessary bureaucracy
and releasing additional funds for good
causes
my government will create invest in new
green industries to create jobs
while protecting the environment
the united kingdom is committed to
achieving net zero greenhouse gas
emissions
by 2050 and will continue to lead the
way
internationally by hosting the cop26
summit
in glasgow legislation will set
binding environmental targets
legislation will also be brought forward
to ensure the united kingdom has
and promotes the highest standards of
animal welfare
my government will strengthen and renew
democracy
and the constitution legislation will be
introduced
to ensure the integrity of elections
protect
freedom of speech and restore the
balance of power
between the executive legislature
and the courts my ministers will promote
the strength and integrity of the union
measures will be brought forward to
strengthen devolved government
in northern ireland and address the
legacy
of the past
my government will introduce measures to
increase the safety and security of its
citizens
legislation will increase sentences for
the most serious and violent offenders
and ensure the timely administration of
justice
proposals will be brought forward to
address violence
including against women and girls
and to support victims
measures will be brought forward to
establish a fairer immigration system
that strengthens the united kingdom's
and deters criminals who facilitate
dangerous and illegal journeys
my government will lead the way in
ensuring internet safety for all
especially for children whilst
harnessing the benefits
of a free open and secure internet
my ministers will provide our gallant
armed services
with the biggest spending increase in 30
years
taking forward their program of
modernization
and reinforcing the united kingdom's
commitment
to nato my ministers will honor and
strengthen the armed forces covenant
placing it in law measures will be
introduced
to provide national insurance
contribution relief
for employers of veterans
legislation will be introduced to
counter hostile activity by foreign
states
my ministers will implement the
integrated review
of security defense development
and foreign policy
the united kingdom will host the g7
summit
and lead the global effort to secure a
robust economic recovery from the
pandemic
my ministers will deepen trade ties in
the gulf
africa and the indo-pacific
my government will continue to provide
aid
where it has the greatest impact on
reducing poverty
and alleviating human suffering
my government will uphold human rights
and democracy across the world
it will take forward a global effort to
get
40 million girls across the world into
school
members of the house of commons
estimates for the public services
will be laid before you
my lords and members of the house of
commons other measures will be laid
before you
i pray that the blessing of almighty god
may rest
upon your councils
the lord chancellor approaches the queen
he
doesn't come to receive the speech back
but
ceremony is observed and with that
the crime is picked up and her majesty
the queen when she's ready will
stand and also the lords with her
the queen will signify her goodbye by
looking to the different sides of the
house of lords saying goodbye with the
bio
and then the sovereign leaves the house
of lords
and the power vested in the sovereign
but carried by
parliament is now as it were released
into the debating
that follows with the bills that must be
looked at and have been
listed and the queen will return to
buckingham palace
and the peers will go to remove their
parliamentary robes
and the chamber will be prepared for its
debate this afternoon
and effectively a tradition that takes
us back to
the very beginnings of royal power
as it was brought into question and
challenged by
others has been played out before us
we saw the appearance of power in the
queen
and we see the reality of power here
with
very much less splendor and glamour
but these are the representatives of the
people
who must now do their debate and that
great building that was
built for these moments now goes to its
real purpose
[Music]
debate
sydney suspended until 2 30 pm
sitting suspended to 2 30 p.m
[Music]
well mps will be back this afternoon to
start debating the queen's speech that
debate normally takes about a week
by tradition it opens with two back
benchers
uh making speeches uh before the prime
minister replies
to them and given boris johnson's
love of oratory uh that will probably be
a fairly
uh amusing uh start to what is going to
be
uh clearly from what we've heard in the
queen's speech a very serious
uh process of government
something around 25 bills announced
centering of course first of all the
government on
getting past the covid pandemic getting
the economy running again
a pledge in that speech to balance the
books
and then legislation concentrating on
the health service social care
uh jobs and also quite a lot of
constitutional reform
well with me is our political editor
beth rigvey uh
what are the main things you think we
should take away from
that agenda for government well i think
the first thing to say was that there
was uh there was a bit of slogan here in
there wasn't there when uh
the queen uh talked about leveling up
the country so the the prime minister
did get uh some sloganeering
uh in there uh from her majesty but look
in terms of the actual substance there
uh you clearly have on the
constitutional issues
quite a clear intent from the government
in that speech it said legislation will
be introduced to ensure the integrity of
elections
protect freedom of speech and restore
the balance of power
between the executive legislation
and the courts now many people would
argue that the balance of
power works quite well thank you as it
is but obviously boris johnson has a big
majority they did not like what happened
over the uh prorogation of parliament
and that been overruled
by the supreme court so i think that
that is
something to watch and see what happens
as that legislation gets laid what do
they actually intend to do
again on the issue of voter id the
integrity
of elections i think that that will be a
big deal
voter id requirement these are figures
from the electoral commission in 2015
they thought
approximately 3.5 million lectures uh
7.5
of the electorate would have none of the
forms of the id highlighted
so is this uh quite a sledgehammer
to crack a nut in that there was only a
few cases
of in in-person
voter fraud in the 2019 election and
cynics
and the opposition would argue that this
is a way of the conservative party to
kind of cut
some people out of elections because it
tends to be people with lower
uh economic status are less likely to
have driver's license and passports so
i think that that will be a big bone of
contention and of course
in terms of the government's agenda the
big push here obviously
on skills uh trying to level up the
country by
giving adults more and better access
uh to education that was the big
government flagship uh
policy in here uh and then of course
adam
the nhs and health a huge backlog of
uh operations from the covered pandemic
building back how they're gonna do that
and on social care as i said earlier uh
nothing concrete in there well
just interesting social care i'm just
looking we are given that once the
speech has been delivered some
background briefing and and this is the
uh
government document on that and and what
it says about social care which as you
say
very vague social care reform will be
brought forward that's all the queen
says uh it said the government is
committed to improving the adult social
care system
and will bring forward proposals in 2021
the bill will include provisions to
improve the oversight of how social care
is commissioned and delivered
facilitate greater integration between
the health
and care services by placing an
integrated care system on a statutory
footing uh it will collect better data
and what we're really seeing is
uh the government committing to further
integration of the health and the care
system
and uh just ends uh pointing out
the need for uh the situation
to improve in social care that one and a
half million people work there
care costs are unpredictable and uh
also the point being made uh that social
care is not just for the elderly there
are many people
uh who for reasons of disability need
social care
in in the uh general population as well
and that's it
i mean the issue is it's not just about
integrating
uh nhs services with social care it's
how do you
fund long-term social care for an
aging population japan and germany they
have different systems where people pay
in
i mean japan if we see where people
really do have
longevity uh into old age they
get over 40s to pay a certain amount
into the system
here we have a system where you have to
start
funding but should we cap that so people
don't lose their entire life savings
into social care that is something
that's been reported the prime minister
is keen on but it's expensive what do
the treasury say
i don't need to tell you about the
economic fallout of the pandemic
and the extremely high levels of debt
the government are facing now we can
obviously run a big debt burden but you
know if you want to be fiscally
responsible
how is the government going to pay for
everything a lot of people are saying
that i mean that was written in that
they are going to
balance the books again or in terms of
day-to-day spending so if you
if you have a a big social care funding
package as well
that's something on top of over
everything else and this is what as i
was saying earlier this is
what damian green told sky news this
morning the former deputy
prime minister he said that people
agreed more money was needed
and the political issues where will that
cash come from when he said to sky news
this morning the root of all of this
is we all agree you have to spend more
money on social care we've got a
threadbare system now
where that money comes from is why it's
proved so politically difficult over
the decades and it looks today that the
government again
is kicking it into the medium term no
bill more proposals i mean it was
promised 22 months ago people have been
asking for this
when was the deal not review he was
asked to look into social characters a
decade ago wasn't it
2011. indeed well let's uh get some
thoughts
on her majesty uh who looked in fine
form uh delivering that speech
in her dress down gear
aleister a strong performance it has to
be said
by her majesty oh definitely and
for her this is very much what she must
do it's her duty
to do what a sovereign must and that is
to
mark the moment at the start of the
session by opening parliament not all
monarchs did it in the old days
but the queen has pretty persistently
made sure that she always does it when
she can and yes
the duke of edinburgh died recently but
you know she
has always been expecting that in an
elderly husband
and so i think she was determined
that she would make sure that her work
carried on as quickly as possible the
ceremony has worked perfectly because
it has delivered the principal moments
of seeing the crown and the monarch
coming into parliament into the house of
lords
for the speech of the monarch written by
of course
the government of the day has been
delivered which is therefore
given a clear indication from the
monarch as to what
is to be done in this particular session
at her instruction
and now it's down to all the
representatives both
in the house of columns and the peers in
the house of lords
to take it where they will but i thought
it was very touching
that for the queen when her husband died
as duke of edinburgh
his eldest son inherited and so the
queen was escorted into the house of
lords
by the duke of edinburgh alistair thank
you very much indeed alistair one of the
heralds on this occasion a dress down
occasion her majesty
pretty spry getting up those steps to
the throne today
do stay with sky news coming up a
briefing from nicolas sturgeon about
lifty of lockdown rules in scotland
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is sky news at 12 noon coming up
the queen outlines the government's
legislative agenda
funding for training and an asylum
overhaul are on the cards but still no
firm details on social care
my government's priority is to deliver
a national recovery from the pandemic
that makes the united kingdom stronger
healthier
and more prosperous than before
a coroner to publish her findings on the
deaths of 10 civilians shot dead by
british troops in valley murphy
at the start of the troubles
nine children are among 26 people killed
by israeli airstrikes on gaza
as rockets have fired across the border
into southern israel
facing questions the billionaire
financier lex greensell gives evidence
to mps over his influence on the
government
plus
[Music]
a live audience returns to the brit
awards for the first big
live music event in more than a year
well good afternoon from westminster the
queen has just outlined the government's
legislative agenda
for the next year this lunch time the
fixed term parliament which means
elections are held every five years will
be axed
giving the sitting government the
ability to call a snap general election
every adult will have access to a
flexible loan for higher level education
and training nhs patients will receive
more
tailored and preventative care closer to
home
but there was no detail on social care
though sky news understands proposals
will be announced
before the end of this calendar year
my government's priority is to deliver a
national recovery from the pandemic
that makes the united kingdom stronger
healthier
and more prosperous than before
to achieve this my government will level
up opportunities across all parts of the
united kingdom
supporting jobs businesses and economic
growth
and addressing the impact of the
pandemic on public services
my government will protect the health of
the nation
continuing the vaccination program and
providing
additional funding to support the nhs
my ministers will bring forward
legislation
to empower the nhs to innovate and
embrace
technology patients will receive more
tailored and preventative care
closer to home measures will be brought
forward
to support the health and well-being of
the nation
including to tackle obesity and improve
mental health proposals on social care
reform
will be brought forward
let's get some analysis on this program
for government from our political editor
beth rigby of course beth they've got to
get it all through parliament but they
have got a majority
so what do they want to do to change the
face of britain
well i think in the the big picture of
it what you saw in
that speech actually pointed back to
what happened at the end of last week
in terms of the local and uh the
national elections
so there was talk of leveling up that
speaks to that red wall coalition boris
johnson's promises
to try and improve uh the lives of
people right across the uk and
particularly in those seats
that backed him over brexit that voted
for him in 2019
and then people again supporting the
conservatives particularly in the
northeast and the west midlands
so there's talk about leveling up talk
about skills there's a bill in there
about
adult education and learning there is a
stipulations that
companies will provide uh more
support they'll be funded by government
but more company support for training
and then in terms of the union he talked
about strengthening the economic
ties of the union one eye clearly on
hollyrood and nicolas sturgeon's desire
to hold a second independence referendum
by the end of 2024
it will be an almighty battle between
the uk government and the scottish
government
it might never happen in this parliament
but there will be a battle we
talked about that at the weekend so that
that's the kind of big
thematically and then in terms of you
know what are the bills
i mean social care is going to be
discussed today
um john stevens the deputy uh political
editor from
the the mail just actually clipped up
boris johnson july 2019 just as he was
elected conservative leader saying on
the steps of downing street i'm
announcing now
on the steps of downing street we will
fix the crisis in social care for all
with a clear plan we have
captioning
not
proposed
limp on again proposals by the end of
the year but nothing on certain
abolishing the fixed term parliament act
means there's now uncertainty as to
whether the next general election will
be in 2024 if they do it
uh why why bother me it was introduced
by david cameron a conservative well it
was introduced by david cameron in a
coalition government to sort of
guarantee stability
um boris johnson wants to have much more
free reign over when he calls and calls
an election
and the the suspicions or the is that
actually what he might well do is call
an election
before 2024 at the moment the election
would be
in 2024 will he bring that forward by
year will he hold it
in 2023 there was also some talk about
whether he might adjust the length of
time for elections
that's a prime ministerial power will he
shorten the amount of time
for campaigning as well so tinkering
around
with elections may be to his advantage
which brings me back to the issue of
voter id that will be very contentious
the requirement
to take your passport your driving
licence another form of id
to the polling stations the electoral
commission in 2015 estimated that 3.5
million people
do not have that sort of identification
and as i was saying earlier
there's only ever been there are only a
few cases uh in
2019 so it is rather as i say in a
sledgehammer to crack a nut
uh and critics will uh think that it's
very cynical and it's a way of
disinfranchising uh some people
beth ruby thank you very much i need
more analysis from you throughout the
day
now this was the first public engagement
for her match of the queen since the
death of her husband prince philip
uh let's bring in uh sky's events
commentator
aleister bruce and aleister her majesty
seemed to
approach her duties in a very
businesslike way
well i expect he was fascinated and has
much to talk about as a result of going
into the house of lords
on her 67th opening and finding it
nearly deserted
and it is almost extraordinary
i think having been so regularly
throughout history and seen it in a
particular way
certainly probably much less smell of
mothballs
as a result of there being less people
in there but the ceremonial we saw today
has basically followed precisely the
structure and form
that it always had and that is the
monarch
arrives in obviously not great splendor
but some splendor with the crown
and you get that sense that something
very dramatic
has arrived and the monarch is very
dramatic it's a focus and head of state
and then you watch played out the
ceremonial
through the opening of the parliament
process
when you see the commons coming from
their chamber to the queen looking less
splendid
less golden less dramatic and yet we
know that our constitution
gives the concept of power to the crown
and yet it is carried out
by the representatives that
constituencies return to parliament
and they now have had the whistle blown
on the start of the next part of the
match
by the queen and that political match as
beth and you were discussing will now
take place and it starts literally this
afternoon but the ceremonial and
structure
whilst everybody was at a distance from
one another
and wearing whatever face masking was
required
with the crown there the queen supported
on this occasion by
the prince of wales who as i pointed out
rather interestingly has
inherited his father's title and say
therefore delivered her to the throne
with that title of duke of edinburgh he
is now the patriarch and she
is very much in the position that she's
always held as head of state delivering
her duty
so the queen not wearing this year her
uh
royal regalia in uh uh rather fetching
ma
matching hat and uh day coat there
i think you describe it as lilac gray uh
can we read anything into uh
how she was dressed i don't think so
she tends to make decisions on the
morning of the day
lilac is one of the colors of well in
the purple
is one of the colors of morning in the
royal
calendar as it were it's one of the
tinctures with purple
and mode so maybe there was a bit of
that but she tends to decide on what the
weather's like and a practicality
and what's available and she runs with
it
but never with any desire to
as it were make that the issue she was
there to do the duty within the
constraints that
everyone in the united kingdom and
around the world and particularly
the commonwealth are facing and
you know she's seen wars she's seen
plenty come and go
and she can take all of it in her stride
and i think what's perfect is that the
ceremonial she
agreed with and gave approval to
precisely marks our constitutional
heartbeat
in its start now of this new political
term
and i know you're very good on this
sapphire broaches she's wearing any any
uh significance of those
i can't remember exactly which ones they
were but they're lovely they look like
clip brooches
and uh she has plenty of them and whilst
i know
all the principal ones that have a state
story like the black prince's ruby was
in that crown can you imagine
worn by henry v at the battle of
agincourt and the little sapphire at the
very top of the crown beside her as she
opened parliament
was taken from the ring finger of edward
the confessor
when henry iii opened his tomb in
westminster abbey
in the 1200s alistair thank you
as ever the most expert commentary from
you thank you
away from westminster a gunman has
attacked a school in the russian city of
kazan
killing seven students and their teacher
and injuring several
others uh sky's moscow correspondent
dana magnay joins us live
with the latest diana there's a 19 year
old former student who went
into his school just after 9 a.m this
morning
and this was the first day after a long
10 day may holiday break that the
students
had gone back and he opened fire not
sure if he targeted them specifically
but
uh at children from the eighth grade so
mostly 14 year olds
he had a pump action a turkish-made
pump-action hunting rifle and there also
seems to have been a large explosion
that he set off in the school because
there is debris that you can see on a
lot of the video debris everywhere
the president of tatarstan and kazan is
the capital
of the tatastan region has toured the
inside of the school
huge um devastation really he's he's
crunching on broken glass everywhere and
as you say eight people dead seven
children
one teacher there's also been some
rather disturbing video come out of the
gunman who was
detained by police and is now in a
police station tied down basically
railing about how he hates everybody
talking about how last
summer he felt a monster come within him
that he felt that he was a god
and clearly he he